the number of countries in the United
Nations has grown over the decades from
51 States in 1945 to 193 today many more
places want to become independent but
national governments almost always
opposed secession
catalonia's Parliament declared
independence from Spain in October 2017
following a referendum deemed illegal by
the central authorities in Madrid Spain
dismissed the region's government and
decreed that a fresh election should be
held Catalan politicians leading the
independence movement could be jailed
for decades if found guilty of rebellion
and Sedition
the autonomous Kurdish region in Iraq
also held a recent independence
referendum it outraged the government in
Baghdad and neighboring countries which
also have Kurdish minorities the Baghdad
government claimed the independence
referendum was illegal and seized back
the lands Kurds had taken beyond their
region the desire for secession is
nothing new there are estimated to be
more than 8,000 ethno-cultural groups in
the world with many independence
movements demanding their homelands be
recognized as countries jean-claude
Juncker the president of the European
Commission said that if every region had
its way the EU would become unmanageable
so who gets to form a state there are no
clear international rules the 1933
Montevideo convention declared that a
region needs for things to become a
state a permanent population a defined
territory a government in the capacity
to enter into relations with other
states
but these are only guidelines ideally a
region would also meet other conditions
such as show that a clear majority of
freely chosen independence respect its
own minorities have a viable state and
settle terms with the state at leaves
and its neighbors in practice all of
these conditions are hard to meet Taiwan
is a modern democratic state in all but
international law it's an island off the
southeastern coast of China which has
its own Constitution functions as an
independent state has democratically
elected leaders and was the first place
in Asia to rule in favor of gay marriage
per head its around three times richer
than mainland China but China regards
Taiwan as a renegade province
it insists that no country can have
diplomatic ties with both itself can
Taiwan only 19 countries plus the
Vatican officially recognize it
Somaliland is another region seek him to
be recognized as a country the
semi-desert territory on the coast of
the Gulf of Aden declared independence
from Somalia in 1991 it has its own
government police force and currency but
no foreign government recognizes it
perhaps for good reason to recognize
Somaliland would encourage other
separatists in the region it would
undermine the already weak federal
government of Somalia and it would
probably lead to war there have only
been two major changes to African
borders since the 1960s and neither is a
success story Eritrea declared
independence from Ethiopia in 1993 today
Eritrea has a despotic government and
its people are mired in abject poverty
in 2011 South Sudan seceded from Sudan
making it the world's newest country
soon after South Sudan formed civil war
broke out displacing 2.2 million people
although a ceasefire was signed in 2015
the country lies in ruin plagued by
hyperinflation famine and violence
independence has a romantic ring many
sympathize with the demand for freedom
but redrawing borders is dangerous and
often causes as many problems as it
souls
you
you